it is great to welcome to the program
Jordan Belfort who is a former
stockbroker author motivational speaker
he's author of the book the wolf of Wall
Street ultimately adapted into the
blockbuster film by the same name back
in 2013 Jordan so great to have you on
today
my pleasure what's going on so I have so
many areas where where we could start
but I think maybe one place would be you
know I've read your book I've seen the
movie are you pleased with the way the
book was adapted into the movie and how
much of a say did you have over that um
yeah obviously I was very pleased you
know it's yeah it's pretty much hard to
go wrong with Scorsese and DiCaprio in
the way and Carrie winter was a screen
writer who adapted my book and I worked
very closely with all of them especially
with um with Leo and with Terry went
there so I wrote all the wardroom scenes
and uh the language in the motivational
speeches in the sales pitches and all
stuff that so it was a really
collaborative experience a lot of just a
great you know you know great taste in
my mouth when it was all over and for
that matter I mean like I think that the
proof speaks in the audience like how
they responded I mean the movie became
like pretty much the biggest cult hit of
all time so it's like he's up there the
Rocky Horror I figure these days that
people just you know just watch it again
and again and again and it just keeps
expanding so it's yeah I'm very pleased
and what about in terms of I mean when
you went when I read your book there's a
lot more in the book about sort of like
your state of mind as you were going
through everything that you did and that
can be hard to translate into a movie
that's a couple hours long from a four
500 page book or however long like it
was it felt very short to be clear but
it was not a short book so what what
about your sort of mindset as you were
going through the building of the firm
and everything that happened there was
one source of frustration with the movie
was that that you know yeah it's pretty
much that that aspect I think that I
think it that the one thing they missed
was the slow the evolution of ethics and
integrity like I didn't it was like in
the movies like I go down to Wall Street
I'm like this really audio
young guy and like can't we make our
clients money and they're like no you
can and the next scene I'm with like at
a strip club snorting coke right that
didn't happen I mean that I went there's
a very good kid never got trouble for
and there was over a period of years as
slowly but surely one step over that
ethical line ate away at my moral Center
for that period of time you know before
you know what you're doing things you
thought you'd never do and it seems
perfectly okay so I mean that pop kind
of got left that in the movie and you
know in addition I think a lot of the um
you know the idea you know of you know
people say well do you feel like almost
like there was no guilt involved that's
I mean every single day I was you know
felt terrible as I was going on and I
felt like I was almost like you know an
actor on a stage in my own life and sort
of going through emotions that's a very
common feeling that a lot of people were
very successful when things of spiraling
out of control you almost feel and it's
not true it's just a feeling you have
you start to believe in you can't get
off the revolving you know there's like
sort of you know the elevators going up
and down you just can't get open you
really can so those things did it make
it into the movie and but the good news
is a TV series that's gonna be coming
out next year early next year at late
this year and that will really delve
much deeper into all that stuff and also
what happened before and after so for
people who don't know there were
ultimately there was an FBI
investigation that in the book in with
the with the 20/20 hindsight that you
have when you were writing the book you
talked about how long it had actually
been going on and it had been going on
quite a long time into you you detail
the drug addiction in the book with all
of this stuff can you talk a little bit
about how from the outside it can seem
like you say like from one day to the
next things are crazy and you're in
completely over your head but that in
reality it's a little bit at a time that
you take one step and then you take
another small step and then before you
know it you're sort of in over your head
yeah it's it's again it's like we as
human beings we become desensitized to
the same things that happen again and
again I'll give you an example the first
time I ever had got a subpoena from an
agency it was the NASD which is a
regulatory body
I think it's called FINRA now right and
they sent me this subpoena and I was
devastated I was like I was like oh my
god I couldn't sleep for a month right
flash-forward three years four years I'm
like I got a subpoena from the SEC a
real agency and I'm like pissing on it I
thought you know it's like and it's
shocking that that you can get to that
point but what happens is as the Martin
word it bless you do that you'll go
crazy you have to sort of learn the
cubbyhole and it's a little box and go
on and that's how you rationalize your
life away right and that can work in
your advantage and also to your
disadvantage depending on the situation
it's a protective mechanism so you can
continue focusing and moving far without
then we going crazy right but it also
leads the behaviors that become you know
skewed irrationally or massively
two-to-one to one side of the equation
because you've lost your the gut check
you kind of you know the realities have
been blocked away and then just acting
without that so so when you're in the
midst of it you know you said that it
would it's not right to portray the idea
that you had no reservations about what
you were doing and that you had no guilt
so to speak but when you're in it what
is the sort of like rationalizing
mechanism that happens where where you
say well I'm nine steps in at this point
I'm taking step 10 for example like what
what is going on in your mind as you
continue to get deeper into it so
remember that is a very big difference
to what I did to what someone like a
Bernie Madoff day so that's right he
made a plea fraud there's no claim being
born is all fiction now in my case 95
percent plus of what I was doing was
legal so what you end up doing is you
focus on the legal stuff right and then
you say what everyone's doing the other
stuff to see you you look to everyone's
doing it so I you can't use that argue
if you're a criminal robbing houses you
can't use that but if you're in the area
where I was just like this sort of gray
area where like you're doing most things
right and yet this one little thing
that's wrong now in in reality that's
still illegal right but you're able to
then sort of say so it's mostly legal
and
everyone's doing that anyway I'm just
better at it and that's sort of the
rationalizing process so I think I've
said a lot of people like for instance
when you have like uh you see a Wall
Street guy who's doing 90% of everything
right like big when the Sanjay's
something or there was a billion
multi-billion dollar hedge fund and the
guy got caught doing insider trading
yeah legitimate hedge fund everything
was right and probably you know if you
did a hundred trades five ROI inside
information one is enough to get you
thrown in jail right but he's safe from
so far everyone's doing it and most of
all I do is Lillywhite so you know it's
that's how it really it gets played out
in your own mind so I want to get your
thoughts on just the regulation of the
financial industry a little bit but in
order to do that I'm curious from
reading the book my sense of you is that
your politics are sort of like socially
do whatever you don't really care
liberal libertarian but that on economic
stuff you might be more of what we would
call like a Mitt Romney type
conservative so to speak am i way off on
that is that roughly your where your
politics are I'm at a socially liberal
as you can get and I wouldn't say I'm is
fiscally conservative I'm very distantly
conservative
I only believe that Trump is on the
right track economically with the things
he's doing real huh yeah oh that's
interesting
I do and the social on the social side
of things
yeah I'm way I'm as liberal you could
get like you know marry who you want
sleep with who you want I mean that's
just like to me it's like I don't really
understand how you can be a conservative
and not be socially liberal they if
you're really thinking through it's
idiotic ly ridiculous
you just think that I want the
government out of my life for my
business and my finances but we should
tell people what they who they should
marry who they should sleep with what's
right what's wrong who should do what
they want with their body I don't see
how you can reconcile those two in a
straight face I think that knows
respects a lot of the message gets
hijacked by the religious right and they
have a very powerful lobby so the
Republican Party is forced to take on
positions they probably mostly don't
believe in mm-hm yes you I'm not but you
honestly think that gay marriage is evil
I mean it's
stupid I mean like people I agree with
you but so you're saying you think some
of the Opposition is insincere from the
right to gay marriage lutely I'm sure
most Emma wishing praying I'm sure Trump
is wishing he could say things about
certain ah he's not he's um he's a
Democrat his whole life the guy he's a
Democrat I'm saying and I'm not
defending him I think he does a lot of
stupid [ __ ] and and I don't like but on
all I would have voted him a hundred
times in a row but Hillary Clinton in a
million not even a close shot so let's
so I'm interested in your insight into
this yeah if she had won I would have
supported her as my president yeah just
right so okay so when you go back to the
things that you did and again you were
working mostly within the legal
framework and stepping outside of it
like you say 5% Donald Trump's view on
economic policy is one of deregulation
right taking away regulations is your is
your sense that the way to deal with the
type of financial industry malfeasance
that you were around is the solution
less regulation or more regulation I
think is the right regulation you know
III that most regulations are completely
ridiculous they all they do is stifle
growth they stifle competition and they
don't accomplish what they were meant to
accomplish because the people who wrote
them what ends up happening is by the
time the regulation passes it got so
watered down by lobbying groups and by
political interests and and by PACs that
what you end up seeing is not a
legitimate solution to what it's trying
to accomplish but it's been hamstrung
and as all this horse trading going on
behind the scenes so I believe that the
catalyst mark is without regulation will
completely run amok because that's the
nature of the human beast they need to
be regulated but that being said the
regulations that are in place need to be
of the magnitude that dissuades any
activity that would lead a girl a not
having his or her it was mutually
aligned with the investor that's the
biggest thing that happens all these
situations where you have a situation
where basically from the beginning
it's a bankrupt philosophy because the
people who are on one side meaning the
brokers traders agents where they are
and the people whose money that they're
managing that what's best for what is
worse for the other right end up
returning end up with people make
misrepresentations right now the hedge
fund model was theoretically a step in
the right direction where you had these
two-and-twenty deals where okay well I'm
only gonna really make money if you make
money 20% the problem with that is the
two is the 2% naívi corrupts the whole
entire thing
because then what happens is is you get
into the asset gather game well just
gather enough assets by gather two three
billion dollars that's forty to sixty
million a year I just make before I do
anything but the problem with that is
then the more assets you gather the
hardest to get people to return in those
assets right you make a good small
amounts of money but it becomes
difficult for large amounts so all these
hedge funds got to these two in 20 games
and if you're looking at Warren
Buffett's right you're much better off
just buying the freaking uh the the
index because the end of day all that is
two things a be the two kills you every
time unless it's an extraordinarily
lucrative fun and those are few and far
between and be the other side of the
equation is that they have to then
justify activity okay so I'm giving you
my money that may stuff have to churn
and trade to show someone you know I'm
doing something with your money so
there's engaging activity that creates
commissions and I think the smartest
money is buy and hold for the long term
and you're much better off just buying
it index than anything else that's like
let's go back because this is super
interesting so you and I are exactly on
the same page that there is a lack of a
fiduciary duty that financial
professionals have to the investor which
creates misaligned incentives the way
that you're talking about now what's
interesting to me about that is you said
economically you like what Donald Trump
is doing but Donald Trump is against
putting in place some kind of a
fiduciary responsibility for the
financial industry like that that exists
with lawyers and with for example real
estate professionals so is that an area
where you agree with all my from the
question you asked was why it was you
know I agree economically now you told
me that regulation the two different
things
I agree that I think that you can't
argue with success
okay whatever Donald Trump has done and
also remember this yeah be fair to Obama
that very much of where an economy is
during the president's first term passed
it with his predecessor that came before
him so it's not all Donald Trump's you
know success here some of it and I and I
again I'm asked you Republican right but
you have to give Obama some credit as
well okay for delivering the economy
even though it was anemic compared to
what it is right now
it's always a let the economy laughs
it's a lesson let's explore that in a
little bit of detail yeah I mean the lag
time economic theory is definitely a
real thing but like for example if we
just look at stock market which I think
for a lot of people the stock market is
not hugely relevant to their lives
indicated to me not only a lagging
indicator so what's interesting about
that is if you look at Obama's first
three years in Trump's first three years
Obama's first three years of the stock
market outperformed Trump's how do we
interpret that I don't look the stock
walk as a bogus indicator of anything
got it
what do you look at he's white sheet
money the price interest it's just like
I already you can't even look at that as
the help of the economy I look at more
GDP things like that you know growth
unemployment rates other appointments at
minority groups I think those are the
more important things of real wage
increases so he knows a farm walk
telling signs for the economy then the
stock market and what do you think is
the lag time in other words for how many
months during president number two do we
attribute the economy to the person that
came before them so to speak well I
think it is to remember these two
factors involved yeah right
there's the policies and then there's
the mindset right so in other words you
have a president that's a cheerleader
for business it's a that promotes
business it creates confidence in people
so people start to spend more they
believe things will loosen up and get
better so all of a sudden you have this
a consequence Tripoli from someone
saying negative loosen regulations which
makes people spend money which results
in growth versus when people think that
laws are going to change
taxes gonna go up and all these things
people will start to clamp there their
their their their financial belts
tighter because of what they believe to
be the future being slower so this is
immediate impact of just having someone
saying here's what I'm gonna do and it
becomes almost a self-fulfilling
prophecy doesn't that only apply though
to like really the the top of the
economy because the average person who's
barely saving well let me let me get let
me just lay it out and I'll give you
time to respond the average person who
is like okay what's toilet paper costing
right now what are what are might what's
my food costing they're not really being
influenced by possible future changes to
the tax law right I mean that doesn't
seem to make any sense I disagree with
that really I think that's that's the
Elizabeth Warren me when she said oh or
the crumbs that on Nancy Pelosi got the
crumbs when you give someone a tax break
and they get back a check for a thousand
or fifteen hundred dollars that's a lot
of money for the average family that's a
lot of money and also in addition all
those people have credit cards or in
other words so much of it is consumer
confidence so it all comes remember that
the country reflects if the collective
will of all the people within the
country it's not just a few mock
rebellion people at the top you know
there's people who are the pictures were
a consumer-based economy we're not a
manufacturing based economy most of our
economy is based on consumer spending in
financial products there's being a
manufacturing base what Trump is trying
to bring that back but come on I mean
that's not what we do it's not like the
eighteen hundred's anymore massive
amount of economic growth here is based
on consumer spending and financial
instruments that are all focused on Wall
Street that's just the bottom line
somewhere I guess where I'm concerned
and you know I I mean my my my view is
clear but I don't I'm not a black white
person on this in other words I want to
look and looking at the details where I
get ya know no I know where I get
concerned is for example when they did
the tax reform in 2017 people started
seeing a little bit more money in their
paychecks but part of that was not
really a tax cut it was that the
withholding tables were changed so
during the year people had a little bit
more money and at the end of the year
they got a smaller refund and their
effective tax rate was basically the
same some people a little more some
people a little less
if your additional spending is based on
a misunderstanding of your tax rate
isn't that bad in the long term
I disagree do I that's not I think what
you said is incorrect really I don't
have the actual who's in front of it
yeah I think it's incorrect by the
effective tax rates go down not for
everybody but for massive amount of
people tax rates they go down the things
I didn't like just to say I'm there are
certain things that really work more
unfair difference for instance you're
penalized heavily for being in a state
that is high state taxes California in
New York where you can no longer write
your state duction so up against your
federal tax right now that was a
disaster for me also changing the
methodology of how you deduct interest
on your home mortgage change drastically
up to a certain so that so there was
things I didn't like about the tax cut
but clearly more money did effectively
get put into the pockets of people and
not just in a deferral basis in a real
basis now if you want to show me numbers
or an actual study that's independent it
says that that's not what happened I'm
opening I didn't know we were gonna talk
about this the studies do exist but in
any case it seems like at least
philosophically we're getting a sense of
where we are so yes your overarching
point and my overarching point is is
that when people think things are going
to get better
it makes things get better when people
think things are going to get worse they
stop spending and it makes things worse
very it's a great part of economics it's
self-fulfilling prophecies and it goes
back to the old from control only be
really the fear is fear itself
fear is paralyzing okay fear stops you
from spending it stops me from buying on
their credit cards that's why George
Bush who I didn't was not a big fan of
the Sun W right yeah we said yeah if you
don't go out spend the terrorists win
like me like after 9/11 you know I'm
saying so anyway I think what you're
missing here though is that when we talk
about economic growth you weren't a very
valid point about the cost of toilet
paper and toothpaste or whatever it
might be the cost of throwing out for
dinner when we talk about economic
growth being a robust four percent right
does that if you take that to the
individual level does that really matter
to someone like why should it matter
because if someone's big but hold on one
second
and I have to interject I have to
interject 4% doesn't exist we Trump
talked about 4% but if we want to talk
real numbers we just got the 2019 report
it was 2.9 I'm not I'm making a
philosophic a all right fair enough I
said I'm talking anywhere in the world
when we talk about economic growth in
general yes being 3% of 5% us doesn't
matter what the number is what I'm
saying is is incrementally to the
individual if your paycheck goes up with
them you even strength about 3% or 2%
there's a really impact your life that
much if you made fifty thousand one year
and forty nine thousand x is gonna
radically alter your existence no you're
still gonna buy toilet paper you're
still gonna buy toothpaste so these
little things like these little three
percent growth is so robust I mean at
the end of the day so much of this is
about perception it's about how much
credit is available for people that to
Meisel really drives so much of economic
growth and I think that regulations
while regulations are important that do
I believe in deregulation I still
believe in financial regulation in other
words I think in the financial world it
needs to be stringent regulation to
avoid the sort of things that happen
back in 2007 that was a joke and a
disaster and it was and I saw it coming
way before it happened they did because
I was in the mortgage industry and I had
been on Wall Street and I knew there was
a disconnect between what people were
saying in reality I've watched it happen
and all I'm saying is that when you're
passing rules I think a lot of the laws
that are on the books that Trump did
repeal were actually really beneficial
to economic growth but I'm not talking
about Wall Street regulation that's a
different animal gotcha
yeah I mean what's interesting is and I
know you got to go in a second what's
interesting is we are analysis of the
growth being a self-fulfilling prophecy
or contraction being a self-fulfilling
prophecy is basically the same where I
go further than I think you go is that
when it is not based on a strong and
real foundation it ultimately leads to
these boom and bust cycles where yes if
the perception is positive you'll get
the spending in the short term but if
it's not built on a strong foundation it
will ultimately collapse the way we
saw for example with the mortgage crisis
where the perception was properties are
going to be worth more the banks were
willing to lend credit was available
like you said but it was a weak
foundation and so it imploded
well that imploded for a number of
reasons starting with the biggest one
being fraud massive wholesale fraud at
Standard & Poor's and Moody's that's
where it begun and that's where really
that was what allowed it that was a
complete breakdown of the system that
allowed companies like Goldman Sachs at
all okay to have pieces of stamp
triple-a that should have never been
stamped triple-a and that's what allowed
all of this to happen and the result was
banged up in Iceland and Greece and
whatnot
separate issue well here's might might
say just to close this whole thing up
because they had to go and yeah no I
don't think we're far in all views but I
think there's a far greater issue here
and that is the fiscal deficit all right
boom we very much agree I think we
definitely disagree on that one so I am
very concerned okay I deeply am
concerned about the size of the deficit
and the continually kicking the can down
the road and you know at a certain point
you got to pay the piper mmm I don't
know how you could say that's not a
problem but I'd love to hear how you say
it's not a problem
well it's a it's a bigger conversation
but of course number one you have to
look at the size of the deficit relative
to GDP growth because if the economy
keeps expanding you can have a larger
number of dollars of deficit but it's
roughly the same percentage so that's
one thing that's important to think
about but if you check out modern
monetary theorists I believe that they
make very strong points about deficits
for economically stimulative government
spending are not bad deficits for bad
government spending like tax cuts for
the rich where the money gets stuffed
into a bank account that is not quite so
good so we probably disagree
philosophically there no it's just those
theorists say you know what they are
they're from terrorists okay well I know
you're in the real world of business in
the real world of life you cannot keep
borrowing and
borrowing and borrowing and not
producing you can't keep consuming and
consuming and dumping money into into
guns and military and all this stuff you
cannot allow the government to just keep
printing money it ain't gonna work ever
and that much I know I'm right about
when that day comes who knows but yeah
why not keep borrowing cuz we do not
live in fantasy land so I know right
most people they work it probably at
goldman sachs and the other companies
and that's why they say what they say
because it's in their interest to say
that the think tanks and all these
people yes they're bought and paid for
was in the real world you just okay well
in the real world you cannot borrow
forever and borrow and borrow and keep
borrowing it's impossible well as a
government is not a household but i
think that that's where we can we will
agree to pause the conversation i know
you got to go jordan belfort don't miss
his book
the wolf of Wall Street also you can
check out the movie but my god yes I
follow you I follow Jordan on Instagram
he has awesome sales techniques and all
sorts of cool stuff Jordan I really
appreciate your time all right thank you